[Musique]
du 4 au 16 novembre 2018 la france
organise le championnat du monde des
courses aventure à événement
exceptionnel un décor hors norme celui
de l'île de la réunion
cette expédition sportif unique est
engagée couru en autonomie réunira un
plateau composé des meilleurs équipes du
monde
les courses aventures sont des courses
non stop en autonomie complète
par équipes les équipes de quatre
personnes c'est des équipes mixtes et
puis ça regroupe tous les sports de
nature qu'on peut trouver sur un
territoire donc sur l'île de la réunion
on va avoir du trech du vtt de l'eau de
kayak en eaux libres ou en mer on va
avoir du canyoning de l'aspect des eaux
on va peut-être avoir du cheval une
fierté pour le président du département
cyrille melchior
en effet plus de 300 athlètes font
foulée nous sentiers remparts un
véritable coup de projecteur sur notre
île est un vrai plaisir pour nous
d'accueillir ce raid aventure sur le
territoire de la région puisque vous le
savez bien
nous avons des paysages magnifiques ne
siècle n'auront pas sont classés au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
on dit que la réunion c'est une île
intense et la beauté de nos paysages est
reconnu aujourd'hui le fait d'accueillir
le raid aventure édition 2010 8 au mois
de novembre
c'est un honneur mais c'est aussi une
façon de dire que la réunion est
reconnue sur le plan mondial les équipes
relieront hell bourg à saint-paul durant
cinq à huit jours de course non-stop en
immersion et sans assistance
il ya forcément des appréhensions
parce que déjà c'est un format très très
long un peu hors normes
il ya des activités qui sont divers et
variés mais on ne connaît pas exactement
ni les lieux sur lesquels on va
pratiquer ni l'engagement qui va falloir
avoir sur le
sur le moment mais c'est ce qui fait
aussi la valeur de cette discipline
c'est l'inconnu donc c'est un petit peu
comme sauter dans le vide donc jour la
compétition découvre le terrain de jeu
est le principe de base c'est
l'adaptation et c'est pour ça que c'est
vous aussi c'est que chacun essayait de
mettre notre compétence
les autres du comté s'est passé la ligne
d'arrivée parce que c'est comme ça au
625 nations seront représentées avec 75
équipes mixtes de quatre coureurs une
aventure de 400 km
[Musique]